>>Shula: Mission Lab is a design
studio within Quest to Learn.
It's comprised of game designers
and curriculum designers
and we work with
teachers at Quest to Learn
to help them develop their
curriculum and to design games
that are played in
the classroom.
>>Shula: Part of what we do is
to identify pieces of content
that students tend to have
trouble learning or picking up
and when those areas come
up, we work as a team
to brainstorm ways that
we can design a game
that will help kids to better
understand and really learn
and remember these
content areas.
>>Arana: Mission Lab is
something as a structure
within a school that
does not exist
in any other school
that I know of.
The support that it gives
teachers, I think especially
at a public school, makes
it extremely unique.
It's just a place where
teachers can really be creative
and are really encouraged to
be creative with our curriculum
and also a space
of collaboration.
>>Eliza: It is an
amazing experience
because you not only have
three heads working together
but you have three
heads that bring
such wonderful different
knowledge and skills
to the table that you
end up with products
that wouldn't have ever appeared
if it was just three
teachers working together
or three curriculum designers
or three game designers.
>>Ameer: The teacher obviously
comes with the content expertise
in terms of what is mandated
to be taught and then through,
you know, group meetings
and discussions
with the curriculum
developers and game designers,
start to flesh out possible
ideas and directions
to go to teach the content.
>>Daniel: The space
that we offer is just
like physically a necessary
place for teachers to go
to that's not like
a faculty room.
It's a place where they can
go and think, not just go
and chill, and we are
there to help them think.
>>Claudio: In terms of knowing
what the teacher wants to teach,
I have some ideas
in my mind already,
but then the teacher comes
up with something else
which is very close to that.
So I say, "Well, actually,
I was thinking the same,"
so when I see that connection
happening, we are almost
on the same wavelength, then I
say, "Oh, we should at least try
to prototype this idea
and see what happens."
>>Shula: When the collaboration
works, it's more successful
in the classroom because the
teacher feels ownership over it.
>>Eliza: We see kids
excited, they're jumping
out of their seats,
they're yelling.
They're talking about triangles
and Pythagorean theorem
and you can just see the
energy in the classroom.
I call it controlled
chaos, it is a lot of noise
but very specific noise
geared towards learning goals.
So it's this amazing
time in a classroom
where you know learning's
going on at the same time
that the students
are having fun.
>>Student: We're not just
playing the games for no reason.
We have a goal in mind, so
our goal for the day may be
to learn certain Spanish words.
So we played Clue once,
but it was a Spanish Clue
and the object was to learn how
to say different Spanish foods.
So by playing the game we were
able to pick up the language
and speak it by the
end of the class.
>>Ameer: At first
you're like, "Oh man,
the second these kids hear
game, their minds change
and they start to get a
little excited, they talk,
they don't listen as much."
And that's true, and
from a kid's perspective,
every time they have
experienced games,
it's been in a more
lax environment
where they're supposed to
have fun and not worrying
about rules or anything else.
So as a teacher, it's your
job to present the game
in such a way that, yeah, we're
having fun, we're learning,
but at the same time, although
you're enjoying this game,
you're still in a classroom and
the ultimate goal is not only
to have fun but to learn what
we're trying to teach you.
>>Shula: One of the things
that gives games so much power
in teaching kids is that
games really encourage you
to just keep trying.
This seems like a perfect fit
with when you're teaching kids,
to teach them in a safe
environment and encourage them
to just try without
fearing failure.
>>Eliza: Oftentimes the
teachers bring up ideas
that we never thought of, and
so it changes the direction
of where we're going in
a particular brainstorm
or with a play test of a game.
The teacher's feedback may then
shift the redesign of that game.
>>Claudio: One block, you
need to touch that with one
of your units so it's touching,
then you can attack
and you can use that.
>>Daniel: Mission Lab and
our meeting times are prompts
for teacher learning and teacher
reflecting on their next steps
when they're long term planning.
It's very easy to get caught
in the day to day as a teacher
and planning for the next
day, or maybe the next week,
or maybe two weeks
down the road,
but we try to force
the long term vision.
And while it can be
a pain sometimes too,
teachers do appreciate
it in the long run.
>>Arana: There's
sort of a trajectory
to understanding the
nature of the collaboration
and so teachers who
have been here
since the beginning are very
protective of their relationship
with the curriculum team.
Curriculum meeting times
are kind of like times
that are never touched
unless they really have to be
and teachers protect that
more than anybody else does.
>>Claudio: Games can
be considered almost
like a second language,
a universal language
for the world, because those
are experiences that a lot
of people go through
and they connect to,
maybe in similar ways.
And so there is already some
kind of connection there,
so if something is working
here, I don't see why something
like this wouldn't
work in other places.